la recherche continue pour améliorer le
quotidien des malades depuis 28 ans
maintenant le généthon travail sur les
maladies rares 80% de ces maladies ont
une origine génétique
le généthon est basé à evry en essonne
et à quelques jours de la 32e édition
l'afm téléthon nous a ouvert les portes
de ses laboratoires
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
avancées g et on est pionnier parce
qu'il a été un des tout premiers
laboratoires à s'intéresser à la
thérapie génique qui est vraiment là
proche de choix pour traiter les
maladies génétiques des maladies
génétiques rares
vous êtes atteint d'une maladie
génétique c'est-à-dire que certains
gènes dans vos organes malades
présentent des mutations
nous ce qu'on va essayer de faire c'est
de remplacer ce gène malade par une
version normale du gène
aujourd'hui nous avons huit produits
sont de notre recherche qui sont en
cours d'expérimentation clinique s'est
absenté des produits qui aujourd'hui
sont injectés à des à des malades et
dans des chants variés puisque nous
avons des produits pour les myopathies
maladies du muscle des produits pour des
immunodéficiences maladies du système
unitaire pour des maladies du sang grâce
à vous des maladies ont été vaincus
mais d'autres restent à vaincre pour
avancer sur les chemins du médicament
très clairement nous sommes entourés
d'experts notamment d'un conseil
scientifique nous sommes entourés aussi
deux scientifiques qui sont dans nos
laboratoires et tous les ans avec les
fonds du téléthon financent à peu près
900 à 1000 chercheurs
concrètement aujourd'hui c'est alors si
j'avais à donner à peu près un chiffre
qui soit assez illustratif c'est 5 % des
maladies rares alors sachant que les
maladies rares elles sont au nombre de
sept mines donc 5 % des maladies rares
pour lesquels aujourd'hui il y as soit
des traitements qui sont arrivés ou qui
vont arriver pas tous en thérapie
génique à ça veut dire qu'on doit pas
oublier lé 95% les maladies rares pour
lesquels il n'y a pas de traitement elle
les avancées concernent notamment deux
maladies la myopathie myotubulaire qui
touche un garçon nouveau-né sur
cinquante mille et dont la moitié décède
avant l'âge de 18 mois
il s'agit d'une maladie dans les
mutations sont localisés dans un gène
qui est qui est localisé sur le
chromosome x donc en soit sien c'est une
maladie qui se manifeste principalement
chez les garçons
de la naissance avec donc une faiblesse
musculaire généralisée c'est à dire que
tout le corps ils ont vraiment du mal à
bouger même à respirer donc la plupart
de ces enfants décèdent dus à une
insuffisance respiratoire et on sait que
le pronostic est très sévère l'essai
clinique a démarré il ya un an
en 2017 il s'agit d'un essai clinique
international qui a commencé aux états
unis et qui qui donne des résultats
assez prometteur pour l'instant et le
syndrome de kriegler najjar un cas sur
un million de naissances environ la
maladie touche le foie dans son corps
elle accumule un composé toxique en
appel la bilirubine qui est un pigment
biliaire qui a une couleur jaune et qui
donc provoque chez elle une jaunisse la
bilirubine est un composé toxique qui
peut atteindre le cerveau et provoqué
des dommages neurotoxiques et qui peut
aller même jusqu'à la mort on estime que
même une restauration de 5% du taux
normal de danse gym qui est manquante
celle et krieger najjar pourrait suffire
à traiter la maladie
donc ça c'est vraiment important parce
qu'on sait que la thérapie génique ne va
pas avoir un effet à 100% mais on sait
que c'est pas la peine de traiter
complètement le fois un petit un petit
pourcentage sera sue sera suffisant en
2016 écrit y pose quelle vie qui produit
les médicaments pensé par le généthon en
2005 et l'on sait il ce thème où
travaillent huit équipes
c'est un institut qui travaille sur les
cellules souches et qui permet en fait
d'étudier les maladies génétiques rares
donc et maladies monogéniques et en fin
de compte nous on va travailler donc
avec cette boutique est important donc
les cellules souches et on va regarder
les différentes applications possibles
autour de ce modèle c'est une approche
différente en termes de stratégie
puisque le jeune et on va avoir une
approche sur la thérapie génique et nous
notre axe thérapeutique en fait se situe
plutôt sur la thérapie cellulaire donc à
partir des cellules souches et on va
également fait modéliser des pathologies
grâce à ses cellules
on
la prochaine édition du marathon du don
c'est les 7 et 8 décembre
le parrain cette année c'est le chanteur
pascal obispo est toujours qu'elle
chiffre à composer pour donner le 36 37
en 2017 l'afm téléthon avait récolté
plus de 2 89 millions d'euros